[Musique]
au mali d'où ils sont aujourd'hui près
de 200 coureurs à participer à cette
première édition du vélo one festival
une course en trois étapes de 35 75 et
95 km chaque coureur se prépare avant le
départ avec des ambitions différentes
[Musique]
la circonstance
le plaisir le plaisir dans la découverte
des sentiers la préparation pour la xt
pas du plaisir
samuel et profiter du paysage
c'est vrai que là le maïdo saab au
terrain violences ayant fait j'ai déjà
dans le vélo mais j'ai la descente mais
oublie seigneur tu viens sur les 84 non
non non j'ai là des files à 35 d'accord
et alors c'est bien de venir maïdo d'une
organisation comme ça
je connais les routes de montagne mais
j'ai voulu essayer un peu
on m'a dit que c'est nouveau
mais la pluie
je suis
[Musique]
aude forestière sentiers piste vtt les
coureurs sillonnent les différentes
voies du maïdo une journée sportive et
familiale qui font le succès de cette
première édition du vérone festival au
moins on en gardera donc c'est vraiment
un très très grand succès vous remercie
tout le monde d'avoir répondu à cudrefin
derrière eux derrière moi pour s'exercer
et pour ce faire fonctionner avec l'aide
d'un moniteur
on a les familles qui viennent découvrir
et profiter beaux paysages maïdo et les
compétiteurs qui veulent se lancer un
défi se surpasser
et
à voir grandir cet honneur d'être
finisher du premier vélodrome festival
de la réunion
[Musique]